growing calls for Attorney General
William bars resignation this comes
after Barr ordered a review in the
criminal case of president Trump's
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn who pled guilty to lying to the
FBI Democratic lawmakers are calling
bars actions unprecedented and say it's
setting a dangerous path for the Justice
Department as the decision triggers more
accusations of political interference
from President Trump the announcement
came as the Justice Department also said
Friday that it was dropping its criminal
investigation of former deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe a frequent target
of the president Li Jiang is traveling
with President Trump and joins us from
West Palm Beach Florida
we do good morning good morning Dana and
good morning to everybody
despite Attorney General William bars
insistence that he and the DOJ act
independently he has been accused of
carrying water for president Trump by
launching investigations just to please
the president like looking into the
origins of the Russia probe and
reviewing evidence collected by Rudy
Giuliani in Ukraine and this morning
there are new questions evolving a case
with the president's first national
security adviser president Trump avoided
reporters on his way to Florida as more
questions mount about Michael Flynn
someone he has often defended they ought
to be ashamed of themselves what they've
done to general Flynn why Attorney
General William bars decision to review
the criminal case against Flynn mr.
Trump's first national security adviser
could be viewed as a favor
senior Justice Department officials
reportedly pushed for a lighter sentence
for Flynn than prosecutors originally
asked for exactly what happened in the
case of Roger stone the president has
never asked me to do anything in a
criminal case Barr insists he and
President Trump did not talk about a
sentence for stone a longtime friend of
mr. Trump's in the same interview Barr
revealed the president's tweets
interfere with his work to have public
statements and tweets made of
at the department about people in the
department are men and women here about
cases pending in the department and
about judges before whom we have cases
make it impossible for me to do my job
CBS News has learned that Barr privately
expressed his frustration to President
Trump for weeks but a defiant president
tweeted he has every legal right to
weigh in on criminal cases in a blow to
mr. Trump
federal prosecutors announced they would
not pursue criminal charges against
former acting FBI director Andrew McCabe
who authorized the Russia investigation
the DOJ was looking into whether McCabe
lied about allowing other FBI officials
to talk to reporters in 2016
McCabe is one of president Trump's go-to
targets and believes that's why he was
being investigated at all the pursuit of
political enemies in the use of the
criminal justice system and criminal
investigations to exact some sort of
revenge on those political enemies is
not something that should be happening
in the United States of America CBS News
has learned President Trump was not
happy about the Justice Department's
decision not to charge McCabe the
president also tweeted that the
foreperson in that Roger stone case
showed bias which may have prompted
stone to once again ask the court to
grant him a new trial Jeff we just thank
you very much
you